thank you so much for making 8 news now
part of your day here at noon i'm
heather mills
across southern nevada deadly hit and
runs are up to an alarming number this
year the latest one happened early this
morning a man in his 50's killed near
saharan jones and this afternoon the
driver remains on the run hector mejia
joining us live hector any updates on
the search for this suspect
no heather so far no announcement from
metro police as far as an arrest or a
vehicle description and according to the
state's office of traffic safety this
marked southern nevada's 17th traffic
fatality from a hidden run so far in the
year this is where the crash happened
we're told that's up from eight hit and
run fatalities we had during the same
time last year
metro police believe the pedestrian
killed by a hit-and-run driver at
saharan el camino was possibly sitting
or lying in the roadway they initially
thought he was crossing the intersection
when he was struck around 1 30 tuesday
morning investigators say the suspect
did not stop kept driving eastbound even
after hitting a man in his 50's he died
on the scene this is a street that
people speed on we know that when tests
were done about how fast was sahara
avenue
that the average speed was over 60 miles
an hour on a weekday morning erin breen
is director of the road equity alliance
project at unlv with fewer daylight
hours she says this typically becomes
the most dangerous time of the year for
pedestrians the equation of people
crossing streets even legally crossing
streets when it's dark and drivers can't
see them heightens the potential for
fatal crashes and so
do everything you can to light yourself
up
and this marks the 112th overall traffic
fatality for the year within metro's
jurisdiction if you know anything that
could help them solve this hit and run
you are asked to give them a call
reporting live near saharan jones hector
mejia live local now